die dunkelziffer der korona fälle liegt
weltweit wohl deutlich höher als die
gemeldeten fälle wie hoch diese
dunkelziffer ist das zeigt jetzt eine
simulationsstudie eines internationalen
forschungsteams sie macht das wirklich
krasse ausmaß des corona virus deutlich
und deshalb wird die eindämmung immer
schwieriger klicks um science-fiction
gibt die spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
das corona virus saß kopf zwei bereitet
sich auf der ganzen welt weiter aus und
das mit teilweise fast exponentiell
steigenden fällen fachleute und behörden
rund um den globus suchen mit hochdruck
nach maßnahmen um die verbreitung
einzudämmen aktuell sind die besten
optionen quarantäne für verdachtsfälle
die soziale distanzierung und ein
möglichst weitgehendes stilllegen des
öffentlichen lebens außerdem spielen wir
ihren tests eine wichtige rolle das
problem dabei ist dass in der regel nur
die menschen getestet werden die
deutliche symptome zeigen oder menschen
die direkten kontakt mit bestätigten
corona fällen hatten bei ausbleibenden
oder schwachen symptomen werden keine
tests vorgenommen und infektionen
bleiben unerkannt weil das
gesundheitssystem das nicht leisten kann
dabei waren es gerade solche oder
entdeckten fälle die in china für zwei
drittel der ersten ansteckungen gesorgt
haben also wie dramatisch das ist zeigt
jetzt die studie eines internationalen
forschungsteams ruhe juli vom imperial
college london hat mit seinem team die
entwicklung der fallzahlen und
infektionsketten im chinesischen wo hand
für den januar untersucht also der zeit
bevor es reisebeschränkungen im
ausbruchs gebiet gab
mit einem erschreckenden ergebnis in der
anfangsphase der epidemie blieben rund
86 prozent der profit 19 fälle
unentdeckt diese unerkannten infektionen
waren schließlich für etwa zwei drittel
der weiteren diagnostizierten fälle
verantwortlich
die heftige ausbreitung in china kam
also größtenteils durch menschen die
kaum oder gar keine symptome gezeigt
haben und deshalb nie getestet worden so
die these des forschungsteams china
bleibt damit kein einzelfall auch in
anderen ländern könnte sich dieses
szenario genauso abspielen und die
rasant ansteigende fälle auch hier in
deutschland erklären
die meisten länder sind aktuell auf
einem
den stand wie china ist vor beginn der
reisebeschränkungen war nach schätzungen
des forschungsteams könnten weltweit auf
einen entdeckten fall sogar sechs bis
sieben weitere corona virus infektionen
kommen
ein ko autoren der studien jeffrey
shaman von der columbia university in
new york erklärt zitat wenn man dies auf
150000 diagnostizierte profit fälle
weltweit überträgt dann könnte die wahre
zahl der infektionen bei einer million
liegen die größenordnung von cola nimmt
also völlig neue dimensionen an als
bislang bekannt war wie hoch die
dunkelziffer in einzelnen ländern und
regionen tatsächlich sind hängt vor
allem von den durchgeführten während es
ab leider gibt es vielerorts nicht
genügend davon in china wurden die tests
nach dem ersten anstieg der fallzahlen
stark intensiviert und man konnte den
anteil der dokumentierten fälle auf etwa
60 prozent steigern so ähnlich lief es
auch in südkorea wo man vermutlich auch
deshalb die ausbreitung des virus stark
verlangsamen konnte das problem ist auch
in deutschland die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems bereits jetzt in der
testphase
es kann einfach zu wenig getestet werden
nachdem berechnung ist eine person die 2
infiziert ist aber kaum oder gar keine
symptome zeigt immer noch etwa halb so
ansteckend wie jemand mit schweren
kowitz symptomen bislang gehen fachleute
davon aus dass ein mensch der mit kuwait
infiziert ist im schnitt zweieinhalb
weitere menschen ansteckt solange er
nicht in quarantäne ist ein symptom
freier wären träger kann das corona
virus immerhin noch auf ein bis zwei
weitere menschen übertragen ohne es zu
merken das bedeutet dass es extrem
wichtig ist gerade in einem frühen
stadium der ausbreitung möglichst breit
angelegte tests durchzuführen eben auch
bei menschen die keine klaren symptome
zeigen so ließe sich das ausmaß
schneller erkennen und man könnte darauf
besser mit maßnahmen wie quarantäne
reagieren in teilen ist es dafür leider
schon zu spät denn dort gibt es viele
schwere fälle und dadurch überlasteten
krankenhäusern groß angelegte tests sind
hier schon nicht mehr zu bewältigen
stattdessen kommt es dort jetzt darauf
an die übertragung des virus bestmöglich
einzudämmen zb durch reisebeschränkungen
und die vermeidung von direkten
kontakten zwischen menschen ob diese
maßnahmen die in vielen ländern bereits
eingesetzt werden aber ausreichen um die
pandemie aufzuhalten lässt sich noch
nicht sagen was wir aber sagen können
ist dass wir alle dazu beitragen
denn wenn jeder von uns auch unbemerkt
ein träger des virus sein könnte
bedeutet das auch dass sie da von uns
dazu beitragen kann dass es sich nicht
weiter ausbreitet also stay home bleibt
also soweit es geht zu hause hatte ich
ja gestern im video tagebuch schon
erwähnt bleibt gesund und bleibt
natürlich auf dem laufenden
hierbei klicks zum science fiction zum
beispiel mit dem video tagebuch hier aus
meiner selbstisolation hier geht es also
hier zur playlist also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren das war passt
ja nichts mehr
bis dann bleibt dran